our next speaker will be hearing ketchup
Kiran is the executive director of the
Yale center for research computing and
the senior director of research
technologies at Yale Karen joined the
staff of Yale and 2013 as I TS director
of research services and in 2014 he was
appointed senior director of research
technology before coming to yell Kiran
served as chief technology officer and
vice president of technology at
betterment LLC in New York City prior to
this karen was the manager of the
development group at the columbia
university center for bioinformatics
karen called an undergraduate degree
from queen's university in canada and an
executive Master of Science degree and
Technology Management from Columbia
University and he is are truly our host
today so welcome Karen
[Applause]
can you hear me canary thanks Steve now
I'm just thinking how am I going to
implement these things exactly that's
right so on that note today we are
actually we're going to see a lot of
great presentations on open data and
research transparency and
reproducibility across a broad set of
disciplines from astrophysics to
political science from American Studies
to outcomes research but underpinning
all of these these disciplines is really
the need for a robust cyber
infrastructure on campuses and you know
as part of that infrastructure it's not
just the technology itself but it's also
access to skill sets on how to use this
infrastructure as well as the training
to keep up to speed with the latest and
ever-changing technology trends on
campus the mission for the yale center
for research computing is to build this
dynamic community to support these data
and computationally intensive needs in
each of these disciplines today we
welcome you to of course the fourth
annual day of data but also to the
official opening of the yale center for
research computing planning for the
center started about two years ago and
today we are officially open for
business as steve had shown if we look
at the the advancements in some of the
scientific techniques so for example the
ability to map the structure of the Zika
virus with cryo-electron microscopy or
the ability to create these 3d models of
ancient egyptian artifacts from
photographs
if we look at the decreasing trends in
costs in sequencing a genome the ability
to sequence the genome for a thousand
dollars now versus the hundred million
dollars just fifteen years ago the
complexities surrounding the
computational needs on campus are
increasing as well and advancing as well
and so it's not sooo not going to be
uncommon where we're going to have to
transfer data at 100 gigabits per second
on campus or store multiple petabytes of
data a day and then archive that data to
be able to keep up with these federally
funded mandates or federal mandates
[Music]
unfunded mandates and so it's going to
get trickier and trickier and trickier
to keep up with these computational
environments and that to me is why a lot
of these tier 1 institutions however are
starting to create these research
computing centers and why there is a
national dialogue at this point on how
to support researchers on campus and
what are the skill sets that are
necessary to do so in the last 12 months
the y crc has been involved in a variety
of initiatives from acquiring funding to
refresh hardware infrastructure the HPC
computing clusters with the Yale Center
for genome analysis to providing
dedicated support to groups like climate
ology or creating orbital simulators
with astrophysics but when thinking
through you know an example of what
demonstrates the broad suite of services
that we offer here at the center what
came to mind is a faculty member who
recently joined the department of
psychology and how we handle that
situation so what we did there was we
prior to her coming to Yale from another
institution we paired her with the
research support group led by dr. Andy
Sherman and dr. Rob bjornsen and they
SAT with her and discussed what's it
going to take to get your data here to
Yale and what sort of computational
environment are you going to need to
process that data given that some of it
is sensitive data
they provided the data management
infrastructure a storage infrastructure
and archive solution to house her
sensitive data they provided her with
access to the computing cluster set up
by the systems administration team at
the computing center they've equipped
her lab with access to the high speed
network on campus which allows her to
transfer data from her lab to the
compute resources at a level much faster
than the standard network on campus they
continue to plan with her what her next
set of investments will be on
infrastructure and they will be
providing training as to how to use this
infrastructure training where we host a
lot of workshops here at the center
since July this past July first we've
trained over 400 people on workshops
such as scripting with Python our HBC
boot camps amazon web services and so we
continue to build out that suite of
workshops so of course we're involved
with everything computational here at
the the research computing center but we
can also be seen as an entry point for
some of the other initiatives that Steve
had alluded to here on campus such as
the data and e science group the
research data consultation group both
out of the library itss research
technology services in IT s we're a
nimble group in a small group but we do
we are complemented by a wifey RIT
steering committee many of you who are
here today who have influenced and
provided insight on the direction of
some of our initiatives were supported
by our two faculty co-directors who are
here Harlan krumholz and dice que no guy
who consistently provided me with
feedback on the pain points on campus
and how we can turn those into
opportunities and then of course we
we've of course had the support of the
Provost's office in the medical medical
school through Steve Durbin and Carolyn
Sleiman and we're grateful for that
we've done a lot we know there's plenty
more to do our office hours are from
nine to five daily dedicated support
hours with their research support groups
are posted on the website as are the
training seminars we thank you for
coming to today's event I do hope that I
get a chance to speak with you
throughout the day or in the coming
months and now as is customary of the
opening of any new center we call Steve
driven to do a ribbon cutting and this
Center to help with research oh
[Applause]